la Organización Mundial de la Salud ha
advertido que muchas personas pueden
morir Durante este invierno
especialmente después de los ataques
contra el sistema energético que han
llevado a cabo Rusia en las últimas
semanas y eso también pone a prueba al
sistema de salud a los hospitales que ya
están bastante golpeados desde el
comienzo de la guerra
todo dependerá de las condiciones
terribles en las que nos dejen nuevos
bombardeos primero si nos dejaran sin
abastecimiento de agua calefacción y
energía lo segundo es cuánto tiempo más
tenemos para prepararnos y lo más
importante es cuánta gente va a
permanecer en la ciudad estos tres
factores nos dirán si estamos listos o
no
el problema general es que si vamos sin
electricidad en la ciudad no tendremos
la posibilidad de enviar a los pacientes
a ningún otro lugar esto es un gran
problema
esto enferma no ha estado
porque pensaba que todo estaba bien pero
ahora resulta que todo está muy muy mal
las enfermedades de viejo se dejan ver
durante el último mes o dos muchas
personas vienen con caso relacionados
con los cortes de Electricidad algunos
pacientes están en la casa conectados a
máquinas de respiración cuando la
electricidad se va no pueden respirar
por su cuenta ellos llaman a los
servicios de emergencia y nos los traen
al hospital
los médicos nos dicen que muchos de los
pacientes no confiesan que uno de las
razones por las cuales agravan su salud
Es la falta de Electricidad y el frío
porque ellos dicen que son conscientes
que las circunstancias por las que pasan
los soldados en el frente de batalla son
mucho peores